we are back with a Fox Business Alert on
this Friday morning stock futures right
now rallying looking to gain back some
of yesterday's big losses Brian hey I'm
seasick the Dow plunging more than 1,800
points it's the worst day since
mid-march we keep setting records both
ways the Nasdaq losing 527 points the
SNP dropping 188 points Ainsley the
losses came as coronavirus cases spike
in some parts of our country and
investors fear a resurgence of the
infections
let's bring in Larry Kudlow director of
National Economic Council he joins us
from the White House so Larry some
people had said that the big sell-off
yesterday was because there's a spike in
cases in a number of states maybe
there's gonna be a second wave was it
that or was it the fact that we've had
such a run up in the stock market people
thought you know what this might be a
good time to take some profits well
that's probably a little bit of both
those are both good points look I'm not
the health expert but I'm the on these
so-called spike I spoke to our health
experts at some length last evening
they're saying there is no second spike
let me repeat that there is no second
spike and secretary Minuten said
yesterday in testimony and I totally
agree we are not going to shut down the
economy what you do have is certain
spots are seeing a little bit of a jump
up some small metropolitan areas are
seeing it the CDC and the health people
are all over it they've sent some task
forces out to deal that you know
nowadays we have much better equipment
much more experience much more testing I
mean the testing itself has jumped up so
you're going to get a little more
positivity from that but if you look
nationally important point is the rate
of increase of new cases is between zero
and one percent it's really flattened
out and with respect to fatalities it's
the same that's actually lower than that
it's like zero to a half a percent so if
I can calm fears again I'm not the
health expert ambassador birx may be out
and about later today nonetheless there
is no emergence
see there is no second wave I don't know
where that got started on Wall Street I
tell you I love the fact that Secretary
of Treasury minuchin says not another
shutdown regardless meanwhile let's talk
about some you have money left in the
PPP program so you know there's a lot of
concern that the time is often they're
going to turn into a loan instead of a
grant so what are the changes to the PPP
program and tax credits that you could
tell the American people about well two
changes from the legislation the
president signed last Friday and by the
way let's not forget last Friday we had
an incredible increase of three million
jobs plus a lower unemployment rate
which shows that the reopening is moving
into economic rebound now having said
that there's about I don't know a
hundred billion plus left in the
paycheck protection program they've done
a remarkable job getting it out in fact
the Congressional Budget Office cited us
for efficiency in getting this things
that there is about a hundred billion
left
I think they extended it the
Congressional legislation extended it I
believe from eight weeks to 24 weeks and
with respect to allocation of the loans
which probably will be forgiven you've
got sixty percent now allocated to
payrolls
so forty percent can go to other
expenses which are important I think it
was a constructive change that the
President did favor so Larry you
mentioned the increase of three million
jobs with the last with jobless claims
report when do you expect that we will
rebound will that be before the election
rebound of the where where we were
before corona well look you know there's
so many green shoots popping up in terms
of early recovery that's what's given us
a much more optimistic feeling I mean
not all is well yet I get that there's
still a lot of heartbreak you still got
a lot of people unemployed so there's a
lot of heartburn on that and that's
going to be a problem but but but but
let me say whether it's the Apple
ability index which shows more people
traveling by car whether it's new
business applications which are soaring
businesses are open automobile demand is
strong housing demand is off the charts
right now back to pre-pandemic levels
there are a number of these green chutes
that suggest number one we are reopening
number two the payroll protection
program did work so what you got instead
of 18 million people on temporary
layoffs it dropped to 15 million people
3 million people went back to work
looking at this now I think virtually a
hundred percent or 97 percent of small
businesses will reopen in the next month
the number is 80 percent according to
the Chamber of Commerce that hasn't been
scored yet so when we get the June
figures in July I'm looking for another
decline in unemployment and another big
increase in employment and I see no
reason why this cannot you know journal
itself through we are looking for 20
percent economic growth in the second
half of the year we reference the
Congressional Budget Office there too
they're seeing similar numbers and a
very strong 2021 and you know president
rebuilt this economy on lower taxes and
deregulation once those things are still
going to be in place he can rebuild it
again we will probably have an economic
growth oriented legislative package next
month when we come around to formal
negotiations so I see the glass is way
half-full and I think America is going
to take off again like a rocket this
hurricane this bad snowstorm this
terrible pandemic virus is going to go
away and we will be okay I mean people
have to keep their chins up I think all
right with an optimistic view from the
White House larry cudlow larry thank you
very much have a good weekend thank you
my pleasure thanks